No right, no wrong, [music] no rules for
me. [singing]
I'm free.
>> Hollywood has waged a secret war against
the very idea of perfection.
>> Our world is built on a foundation of
stones. See, we have these laws that
[music] are written in stone. Literally
written in stone.
>> This message against perfection keeps
repeating itself across multiple genres
for over 30, 40, 50 plus years. Look,
it's Koopa's 10 coupe commandments.
We've got to free the mushroom people
from Koopa's terrible coupe mandments.
>> If Hollywood does have this secret
pattern in their movies, why do they do
it? Most importantly, what do they want
from you? I think we actually have a lot
more in common with the villains than we
think we do.
>> How?
>> Like which villains?
>> A lot of villains.
>> I mean, I I see this concept repeating
over and over and over again. motive for
the villains. I'm going to say that, but
I think that we agree with them.
>> Okay. Wait, wait,
>> that's pretty controversial.
>> Well,
>> now are we talking real life villains or
are we talking
>> movie villains? Some very popular movies
that are out there. Okay. So, um I mean
I'll just throw out one of the most
analyzed movies by Christians, The
Matrix.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> All right.
>> Who's the villain in that one? I've
never seen The Matrix in my life. So
supposedly it's these three guys that
look alike, talk alike, and speak each
other's words. Well, we kind of all
believe that there's three people that
sort of share each other's words and
look alike. Okay.
>> If you don't know about the matrix and
its connection to Christianity, um maybe
you need to click on some some other
videos here. We'll put
>> I mean, we got some videos on it.
>> But the architect of the matrix is like
God. It's why he says, "I am the creator
of the matrix."
>> I am the architect. I created the
matrix.
>> And when he's talking to Neo, he's
basically breaking down that he created
the world to be perfect.
>> Oh, I see where you're coming from.
>> But the humans wouldn't accept it. And
so therefore, he had to add the flaws
into it.
>> But perfection.
>> Wait, who who added the flaws into it?
The humans or the
>> the creator of the matrix? So he
basically said that people can't accept
the idea of perfection.
>> So do you agree with that then?
>> I believe that we uh as humans, we've
lived in such a flawed world, we don't
we probably don't even understand or
know what it's like to be perfect. It's
a hard concept for me to even wrap my
mind around. I can't wait till the day
we get to heaven, though. And everything
is perfect. I want that day.
>> So you agree with part of the concept.
You don't agree with all of it. That's
why I said like I think we have
something in common with some of these
villains because um like when is the
devil ever perfect,
>> right?
>> He's not. Right. And so I think that
these movies just kind of put this like
tainted world view in your mind that
perfection is not possible
>> and we can't we can't understand it. We
can't know it.
>> It's not always a straightup villain
either. Sometimes it's just an authority
figure. Mhm.
>> It's like the um Little Mermaid, the
live action that Disney made. There was
a little short that they put out and
it's her father's voice saying, "You
broke the rules."
>> You know, just straight out, you broke
the rules.
>> You broke the rules. You went to the
above world.
>> A man was drowning. I had to save him.
>> This obsession with humans has to stop.
>> I just want to know more about them.
It's like my curiosity
>> supersedes what I'm being told. Which is
interesting because you kind of break
that down and analyze it. What is his
occupation? Her dad.
>> What is it?
>> He's like the the guy with the Triton,
right? He's like the king. Yeah. Right.
>> Interesting.
>> So, you have a daughter. You have a
king. You see this over and over in
Disney. She's kind of rebelling against
the king. The will of the king.
>> Interesting that that that Yeah. That
it's the king because I mean Frozen kind
of had that kind of concept too, right?
Yes, it was a king. Yes, it had the same
concept in fact.
>> Yeah. And then that song, let it go, it
doesn't say like no no rules,
>> no right, no wrong, no rules for me. I'm
free. Yeah.
>> Same song. She says that perfect girl is
gone.
>> No right, no wrong, no rules for me.
[music]
I'm free.
That perfect girl.
She's rejecting that idea of perfection
for herself. There's a line in the the
second one, Frozen 2, where she's in
like this vision or dream sequence and
it's her grandfather and he's talking
about spirits and magic and how people
shouldn't have anything to do with it.
And he ends his like monologue saying
people think they can defy the will of a
king. The North Uldra follow magic,
which means we can never trust them.
>> Grandfather,
>> magic makes people feel too powerful,
too entitled. It makes them think they
can defy the will of a king.
>> That is not what magic does. That's just
your fear.
>> And then that's when um Elsa has this,
you know, averse reaction to what he's
saying and she's like, "That's just your
fear talking." you know, she's like
defending magic and being able to use
magic because she uses it.
>> So, speaking of kings, um, a couple of
months ago, I I analyzed Shrek.
>> You guys ever seen Shrek? I'm sure you
have.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like the first one. I don't know.
>> Yeah, I saw the first one.
>> It It's such a huge franchise. I mean,
now you have the um It's probably
Universal Pictures or something like
that that has the Shrek at their parks.
One of those studios with the parks has
it. Uh, yeah, like books, all kinds of
things. But you know there's also a king
in there. Do you know who I'm talking
about? The villain.
>> Lord Farquad.
>> So he is a lord who wants to become a
king and he actually has a perfect
kingdom. And yeah, you can see there's
there's this book that you can buy like
a physical book about Shrek. It's called
something like um uh oh Shrek the
complete guide. It actually says that
this city that he runs called Doolock is
insanely neat. It's orderly. It's
spotless. has trees clipped with into
perfect cones. And the castle where Lord
Farquad lives has a perfect penthouse.
And and there's a line actually where
the the actor who plays Shrek, you see
him recording it where he's like, "My
perfect kingdom." So everything is like
lined up for this to be perfect, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um, and it's fascinating when you see
the little details they put in there
that there when Shrek and Donkey enter
Doolock,
they can they see all of these different
angles of Doolock and it's completely
blue. The whole city's blue and then
there's just like this tiny little
corner where you can see the blue has
been painted over, but they haven't
finished it yet. And there's a bucket
with blue paint and underneath it was
brown.
>> And I was like, well, that's
interesting. I mean, you know, what does
the color blue represent in the Bible,
right?
>> It means the law.
>> It's the law. And so, he has this
perfect city. His whole city is is a
color of the law. He's a perfect king.
He's a lord. He wants to become king
because in order to become king, he has
to marry a bride and and have like a
wedding feast, which is all the super
biblical symbology. And on top of that,
do you guys remember that clip where
they they walk into the city
>> and he pulls the little lever?
>> Yes.
>> Do you know what I'm talking about? Have
you know what I'm talking about? It
>> has been so long. I know.
>> Okay. Okay. Let me let me show you this.
>> So So this is like it's like a welcome
center thing where they pull a lever and
there's these puppets that come out kind
of like what you see at like Disneyland
and stuff, you know, like those puppets
that sing. Um and they sing about the
perfection of the city. But then there's
this other episode that came later on.
And it was like a Halloween special. It
was like um Scared Shrek where they come
back. This is like future tense. So like
D is now abandoned, right? It's
abandoned city and Lord Farquad has been
defeated. And they go into the city and
they see this thing again and they pull
it again. So I'll show you guys the
before and after. It's really wild.
Here, watch this.
Have some rules. Let us lay them down.
Go make waves. Stay in line and we'll
get a look. D is a perfect face. We give
up on the grass. Shine your shoes. Wipe
your face. Do
love is love [music] is
Look, it's that little thingy you love
so much. remember
[music and singing]
>> it's a creepy town was once now it's all
dead we will chop off your head and then
laugh when you're dead is a creepy place
come on in the fall down for your face
like do
do what is a creepy.
>> Oh, let's do that again.
>> Did you notice the colors that were in
that though?
>> What are the colors that the people were
wearing?
>> Well, the Yeah, it was blue, right?
>> No.
>> Was it not?
>> Purple and scarlet.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Well, it was blue,
purplish, red. Yeah. Yeah.
>> The clothing that the people that are
singing that song are purple and
scarlet. I think that's kind of
interesting. Just
>> It is interesting. mentioned that
before, but
>> but did you guys notice how they had the
the rules?
>> Yep.
>> And did you notice how in the Halloween
clip, the guy with the rules with like
the the wig that represents like a guy
with holding the law, right? Justice
system. They usually have those wigs.
>> Yeah. His head off.
>> His head he his head gets chopped off
and then he gets burned.
>> Mhm. Interesting. [laughter] Yeah. I I
think that you see that common theme of
basically making this look unappealing.
>> Yeah. I mean, I've seen that in so many
different movies. And and not to make a
kind of a crazy correlation with that,
but do you did you ever see the clip of
the reason why the I guess he was the
ruler of the universe or whatever in
Guardians of the Galaxy? He was the
black guy that was that had made the
little raccoon kid. That guy, do you
remember his motive of why he did that?
He was trying to make a perfect society
and he wanted that being to be perfect
and that was an anomaly that came out of
his creation which then he was like I
wanted you to be perfect and you became
this other thing and all this kind of
stuff.
>> All I wanted to do was to make things
perfect.
>> But that was the main motive of of why
he was doing that.
>> He's wearing purple.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah. Colors played off a lot. Yeah. Um,
I think it's Ugly Dolls
where they have the,
>> you know, the reject dolls. They all
live in a community called Uglyville.
But it's very bright. It's very
cheerful. It's very colorful. There's a
lot of singing, a lot of happiness.
>> And then they go on this journey to to
find, you know, where they're created.
And they go to this place and they wind
up there. And it's called the Institute
of Perfection. Mhm. But everything about
it, it looks like a cloudy day all the
time.
>> It just looks overcast. Everything is
gray and drab and kind of boring. But
the people there are considered
>> perfect.
>> Yeah. But they all look the same.
>> Yeah.
>> There's like a very cookie cutter. Yeah.
Not a lot of variety. Some variety, but
not a lot. Yeah. Just very orderly. They
even have um there's a scene in there
where they have uh oh what is it called
from that Da Vinci drew like the
anatomical man or whatever. Yeah. They
have one of those and like the the
dulich kind of you know showing the like
the perfect body or whatever you know is
is laid out there. Well, I think that
was one of the main characters that was
in that was was actually like the
epitome of perfection, but it found out
that he was like
>> lying or whatever. Yeah. He had like
this storyline that it was like he was
actually not a nice guy.
>> Right. Right. And that's that's very
common is to portray that perfect
character as not a nice guy.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It was the same in um in in Shrek
as well that Lord Farclquad even though
he was trying to get all this
perfection, people were scared of him
because he was his tyrant, you know,
like he just wanted to and force
everybody to follow his ways and his
wills. Um and it's like like at the
wedding feast, you know, when when you
go to a like a live show, they hold up
signs like laugh. So that's what happens
and it's like well you better laugh
because otherwise Lord Farquad is, you
know, so it's it's it's like everything
is forced.
>> Exactly. and he had a very very much of
a depiction of God, but then he's like
an absolute horrible person. And Shrek
comes in and they just basically this
whole movie ends up with perfection
being destroyed and everybody being set
free and embracing imperfection
>> break.
>> Here we are. It's the end of the year.
>> We have been so blessed by your
generosity, your prayers, and [music]
your comments.
>> Every year we aim to finish strong. And
to do that, we need your help. We have
just hired a new person because we want
to make some amazing videos, but there's
a cost.
>> In this room, we will soon have a video
LED wall and we want to utilize that
tool, but there is a cost.
>> We want to take care of our employees,
but there is a cost.
>> You know, Jesus came to this earth to
give us eternal life, but there was a
cost for that.
>> We want others to experience eternal
life as well, and so we ask for your
help. Please consider making an end
ofear gift to one of your favorite, if
not your favorite, ministry. And you can
do that at lls.tv/g
by texting Little Light at 53555
>> or by scanning the QR code on your
screen.
>> You know, I can remember when I first
saw the use of color as some sort of
metaphor for um for either God or this
world that he's created was in
Pleasantville and they We made that way
back when
>> and I mean that whole movie was like
black and white and as they began to sin
they began to to demonstrate more color
and and see more color all the way to
the end where there's the judgment scene
and now you've got these people that are
all black and white because they're like
old school and they all follow all the
rules and the people that have all
changed color are the more exciting
people and everything and there's like a
whole judgment scene and everything.
Wait, there's a judgment in that heart
and it has
sw and they have the apple.
>> The color in there is is is crazy. The
symb the symbolic nature of it.
>> He there's a there's a scene where the
mayor, who's the judge, he says, you
know, he was in Thank God we're in a
bowling alley.
>> Well, we're safe for now. Thank goodness
[music] we're in a bowling alley.
>> What's a bowling alley? The pins are
what? Black and white,
>> right? It's filmed black and white. Why?
Black and white is this metaphor for
right and wrong. Very cut and dry.
>> Right.
>> Right. And then you introduce color.
>> Think about it like when you when
there's language that is uh
inappropriate, people will oftenimes
call it colorful language,
>> right?
>> Interesting.
>> So, it's this and then this scene where
she um I think it's after she grabs the
apple.
>> Yep.
>> Do you know what happens after that?
>> They kiss, right? They make out in the
car. Mhm.
>> Yeah. But do you know what happens
shortly after that?
>> They become colorful. [clears throat]
Oh,
>> whoa. Now that's deep because
>> the story of Noah.
>> Yeah. Just like in the story of Noah. It
starts to rain
>> and that's and that they and then in
Pleasantville they have the same
reaction to the people as the flood.
Like
>> what is this? Like what's going on? Like
they've never seen rain before. They're
all scared. They don't know what to
think of it,
>> right? And then that, you know, the
story continues to progress. But
>> but that's interesting because the story
of Noah ends with the flood and the
sinful people were destroyed. Whereas in
the movie Pleasantville, they just keep
living on.
>> Well, it becomes colorful, which is kind
of a a smack a little bit. I would say
it's kind of a smack on God because
after the rain, 40 days, 40 nights, what
does God do? He puts in a rainbow of
color denoting his promise.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that that that's where I
think like this is not a correct
perspective that they're putting out
there of God or his government or
anything like that, but they're almost
making it non attractive or non-
enticing. So that when you see these
things, you're just like, "Oh, I don't
want to live in that world. I want to
live in the colorful world that,
>> you know, the ugly dolls kind of had."
And where it's like you're embracing all
the imperfections
and all the rejects. I mean that in Ugly
Dolls, wasn't that the story? like they
were rejected.
>> They're rejected now because they're all
messed up.
>> They're confined to a particular part of
the world.
>> They live in Uglyville.
>> They live in Uglyville. And
>> what about something more recent Barbie
movie?
>> That was a hype. That we got a video on
that on our channel, too. But that was a
complete hype. I mean, I remember just
every brand under the sun wanted to do
something pink just to promote the movie
or get themselves promoted.
>> Um, but yeah, same thing. Perfect world.
Mattel, the business of the guys that
were, you know, putting the ideas out
there. They were the ones that were like
>> gray and fake plastic world.
>> Yeah. So, the idea behind it was like
they live in a perfect world. It's the
same as with the Lego movie. Same with
the Barbie movie where it's like this
song of like everything is perfect,
everything is awesome, everything is
going great until all of a sudden
Barbie's feet get flat. She has cellite.
She falls off her roof. Like
everything's has stinky breath.
Everything goes wrong. She starts
thinking about death even. And then she
ends up going to this um h it was like
either ugly Barbie or um crazy Barbie,
weird Barbie, something like that. She
represents the Barbie that kids reject
and they just like scribble on and stuff
like that. So it's interesting that
their whole world is colorful, right?
Even in the trailer, you see the world
where they live in. It's like a heart
shape and inside the heart shape, it's
all lush green, bright blue, and outside
is stormy seas and dull, right? So, she
goes to this Barbie, this weird Barbie,
and she's like, "Hey, so, um, what's
going on? I need some help." This weird
Barbie, mind you, there's a clip of the
actress Kate McKinnon, who says, "My
character is kind of like a shaman
figure."
>> The character was designed as this like
almost shaman figure.
>> What does a shaman do?
>> Uh, that's a witch doctor,
>> right? It's like connecting you with the
spirit world with the darkness and
stuff, right? So this weird Bobby tells
Barbie like, "Hey, you should go check
out the real world." And she's like,
"You got high heels? Well, you got
Birkenstocks." Barbie originally chooses
the high heels, but then she's like,
"No, you have to want to know. Pick the
Birkenstocks." And I think the reason
for it is the metaphor of like um the
the in Barbie world, they have their
feet up, right? This is what Barbie
dolls have. They have their feet always
like this because they step into the the
high heels. And so for Barbie to pick
the high heeled shoes, it's like I want
to stay. But to in order to if you pick
the Birkenstock, you're accepting your
flat feet that need arch support. You
should go into the world.
>> The Matrix all over again.
>> It is because there was actually um
there was this program this
>> Mojo Mojo on YouTube actually compared
that clip to the Matrix. Redo.
>> Yeah. So she goes into the real world,
brings Kent along like, "Hey, Adam and
Eve, they actually left the perfect
world of the Garden of Eden to go into
sin, right?"
And it's like you said, it's it's Mattel
who is the toy company who is portrayed
as a creator.
>> Wasn't the guy in in their um wasn't
that Will Ferrell that played that part
as well as the owner?
>> He was in there.
>> He was in the Lego movie.
>> The Lego movie. Yeah. And the same kind
of character that was actually played in
both of those. Interesting. So, so
Barbara Handler, she's originally the
designer of of the Barbie um doll. She's
actually Barbie ends up talking to her
ghost, which is already really weird.
But she's originally the the creator,
right? But then Mattel as a company is
also seen as like a type of creator that
but that keeps them trapped and and and
all these different things and
>> just exploiting the people for their
>> Yeah. And their offices are gray and
dull. And you know what's interesting is
that these people they walk they they
talk and walk like almost like robotic
people and they follow the lines.
>> So do you remember you guys remember in
Wii but the they had to follow the
lines.
>> I remember this commercial when I was a
kid and I don't remember what company it
was. It was a car company. It might have
been Jeep
>> but it was this monologue where the
person doing the voiceover is like stay
within the lines. The lines are our
friends. And of course they're talking
about driving down the road. Of course,
after that, it's transitioned to like
off-roading and, you know, not staying
in the lines. I mean, crazy. But it's
appealing to people's nature that says,
"I don't want anybody over me. I don't
want to be questioned by an authority. I
want to do what I want."
>> It's true.
>> I don't want anybody to tell me what to
do. You know, I'll just be to my own
drum and have my own rules.
>> I just think it's so interesting that
this keeps showing up over and over.
Like in Barbie movie when when she's
trying to escape the the motel building,
Barbie jumps over the turn styles, but
the motel people cannot. They they use a
car to like beep beep to to unlock it
that they can get through. It doesn't
work. So they're like, "Ah, well, we
give up the chase." And then it's like,
"Oh, get through. Like we can we can
keep chasing her." Like they will not
they have to follow the rules. Same with
Wall-E like we talked about.
>> Same with um Shrek. Remember Shrekines
like Yes. He's has to walk like and
Shrek the the little guy. Do you
remember that that that that clip? It's
at Doolock and this little guy with this
big Lord Farquad head on him like um
>> Yeah. Shrek wants to talk to him and
he's just like ah.
>> Yeah. So that but the guy even though
he's being chas chased by Shrek, he
walks through the little walks the path
he's supposed to walk but then Shrek
walks right through it and breaks the
perfect path. We see this over and over
again.
>> Yeah. you see this pattern um and
usually it's never spoken of as a
positive thing that you're following.
Those rules are laws, right? That's what
it seems to be. The end result of that
is like those rules are meant to be
broken and when they're broken, there's
something beautiful about breaking those
rules. The Bible has actually a lot to
say on perfection here. I want to read a
couple of things that,
>> you know, Matthew 5:48 says, "Therefore,
be perfect because your heavenly father
in heaven is perfect." We should desire
that. I think that's why like um you
know Paul was was penning like look even
if I if I haven't become perfect yet I
want to aspire to be perfect. Like
that's this is something that I'm trying
to do.
>> Um
>> and so I think perfect perfection is is
mostly spoken about in the Bible as as a
heavenly trait or like God's trait is
perfect. Um, I don't ever hear that in
the Bible attributed to the devil.
>> Yeah. There's not this consistent theme
through the Bible of like break the
rules,
>> do what you want.
>> That that's not the theme.
>> There's a there's a great verse. It says
in Psalm 19:7, it says, "The law of the
Lord is perfect, converting the soul.
The testimony of the Lord is sure,
making wise the simple." So, you think
about that. Without God's law, how can
your soul be converted?
>> That's very true,
>> right? This is a guide. And and so
again, you know, you see this in things
like Smallfoot is another example.
>> This perfect world.
>> Yeah. Even has that song perfection.
What could be better than [music] this?
It is what it is.
>> And you know he he explains why that is
because they have these rules that you
know these stones that have that govern
their society. You they have rules that
are written in stone. He says that rules
that are literally written in stone.
>> See we have these laws that are written
in stone. Literally written in [music]
stone, interpreted and enforced by the
stonekeeper.
>> And enforced by the stonekeeper. I mean,
you sit there and you're thinking about
this and it's like, hello. Like, does
this not sound familiar?
>> And you get to the end of the thing, you
find out the stonekeeper is just, you
know,
>> lying.
>> Lying to everyone, keeping them dumb,
and hiding the truth from them.
>> What does that teach kids?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, what if everybody broke
all the rules all the time?
>> You'd have chaos.
>> Chaos, right? So,
>> what about Lego Movie?
>> Lego Movie, same thing. You wake up at a
perfect time.
>> You guys worked on that, right?
>> Follow the rules. That's what he was
doing was following the instructions,
reading all of the instructions in the
beginning.
>> And and yeah, I mean, it's like uh I
think he was even kind of alluding to
the perfection when he said everything's
awesome, right?
>> Oh my gosh, I love this song.
>> Yeah. They they portray it as being this
perfect world where everybody follows
the rules, follow the lines. Do you know
that they play the song at the end after
that's done away with?
>> Oh, that's interesting.
>> So, what they do is they play that song
in the beginning when everything is
awesome. It's perfect. You see,
everything's in perfect working order.
People stand in line, the whole bit.
>> And then at the end
>> when they creativity now reigns, they
play the song again. So, they've
reassociated the song in your mind that
it's awesome when it's perfect and you
can do what you want, not when you have
to obey the rules.
>> I think there's even a line in there
that talks about freedom Friday, right?
And it was like do whatever you want and
you can break the rules. I mean I think
that that um the lady that's playing
Wild,
>> what was her name? Wild.
>> Yeah, Lucy. But it was called Wild
something or other in there. But anyway,
Lucy that that that character was
encouraging people like to we're going
to let this Friday be known as Freedom
Friday or whatever. And it was like
meant to encourage everybody that was
watching all the TVs like do whatever
you want. Think about what Friday is to
our society right now.
>> Yeah.
>> What is it? I mean, it's like the I'm do
whatever I want. Let's go party.
>> So, I think that there's these cultural
things in there that I I think are very
interesting and and very different than
what the Bible's teaching.
>> And then there's the man upstairs in
Lego Movie.
>> Yeah.
>> Which that in of itself. When I first
heard that, I was like, "Wow, come on."
And he's the one who uh uses the the
rule book or the instruction manual.
>> He says he he encourages them, "Be sure
to follow all the instructions. If you
don't, we'll put you to sleep.
>> Exactly. So he he encourage he says to
them, you need to follow the rules and
he uses the rule book or the instruction
manual to to create all of these beings
and and the Lego world and and uh he's
called the man upstairs, but he's a
tyrant again, right? He seeks
perfection, but perfection should be
rebelled against.
>> Yeah. Because in that one when when um
when he was describing to the was it
during the cowboy scene there was
something in the cowboy scene.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You showed it to me. Yeah.
Yeah. She actually describes what he is
really like. Lucy describes Lord um the
man upstairs.
>> All the people of the universe were once
free to travel and mingle and build
whatever they [music] wanted. But
President Business was confused by all
the chaos. So he erected walls between
the worlds and became obsessed with
order and perfection.
>> Yeah. That he basically wants perfection
and that's what he wants or something.
>> He actually has a quote. It's and they
call him two different things. Lord
business or president business. He says,
"All I'm asking for is total
perfection."
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's another um concept of the
really slamming perfection in Tron.
>> They remade that. It's a story about a
father and it's like he finds out that
that you know he he he realizes that
perfection is not possible and that's
what he's been promoting to his son the
whole time. The one that looks like a
younger version of him which is really
even ironic that it's a version of him.
But anyway, perfection there is spoken
about as this is not possible. You
cannot get to this place and that's why
the whole world begins to crumble down.
>> I took the system to its maximum
potential. [music] I created the perfect
system. The thing about perfection
is that it's unknowable.
It's impossible, but it's also right in
front of us all the time.
You wouldn't know that because I didn't
when I created.
>> Yeah. I I think that you can see a
pattern here throughout the whole movie.
And then we are just picked on a few of
them. Like there's so many movies. And
again, you have to ask yourself the
question if you see this over and over
and over and over and over and over
again. Like
it's seriously like who who's actually
running the movie industry when you
think about that?
>> And they're buzzwords to things that are
linked with spiritual concepts like
lawgiver, king,
creator, lord, all those that are
actually physically talking about like,
you know, God, but it's like they're
putting this negative connotation to it.
So it's when you hear that word and you
hear something negative towards it,
that's what sinks into your mind, plants
that seed.
>> It's interesting too the way the Bible
describes Satan. If you look in Ezekiel
28, God is describing him and he says,
"You were perfect in your ways from the
day you were created." Think about that.
God is saying you're a perfect being.
Everything about you was perfect.
>> So what changed?
>> And then he says, "Till iniquity was
found in you." So when sin,
right, transgression of the law, when
sin was found in him, then he's not
perfect anymore.
>> So that kind of goes back to the
previous verse we alluded to, you know,
which says
>> the law of the Lord is perfect,
converting the soul. So he became this
unconverted being.
>> So you never find this pattern in the
Bible that breaking specifically God's
law is a good thing.
>> It's always negative. It always has bad
consequences.
>> I don't think that God is ever telling
you, "Okay, well, it doesn't matter
anymore. Go ahead. Break the rules. Make
your own path." I mean, think about how
much of our cultural society has gone
with that. Make your own way.
>> And yet, a lot of our because I've asked
I mean, I had a a friend that worked for
the sheriff's department. He asked a
lawyer about this. He's like, you know,
do you know what our laws are based on?
The lawyers are like, "Oh, yeah,
absolutely. I mean it's based heavily in
Mosaic law
>> like the laws for this country are are
come he understands they come from
Mosaic law straight lawyer.
>> Yeah.
>> They used to actually be based on the
Bible and they um did away with that
when they took the Bible out of the
schools and wanted to really separate
that heavily and it became case law. So
now everything's balanced back at case
law. But yeah, they were all
foundationally
rooted in the Bible.
>> Yeah, I like what you said, Keith. Uh
that's you know sin is a transgression
of the law. 1 John 3:4 says and this is
a new King James version but King James
specifically says sin is a transgression
of the law. New King James says whoever
commits sin also commits lawlessness and
sin is lawlessness. But also Romans 7:7
what shall we say then? Is the law sin?
Certainly not. On the contrary I would
not have known sin except through the
law for I would not have known
covetousness unless the law had said you
shall not covet. Um, so and there's
another verse as well somewhere that
talks about the law being like a mirror.
>> That when you look into the law, you see
your sin. When I look into the mirror, I
see I have filth in my face. And in the
case of the law, it doesn't mean that
the law can save us. It doesn't mean
that we are, you know, believe in
righteousness by works. Not at all. But
you know, when I look into the law and
it says, hey, you sinned here, I can see
that and I can say, Lord, one, will you
forgive me? and two, will you help me to
overcome my sin?
>> But yeah, if you do away with this and
you say, "Ah, there is no law." That's
like, well, then you're what you're
saying is you can go and and get
yourself five wives now and you can go
kill that guy and steal that thing. And
you know, that's when it puts things
into perspective.
>> Well, when you start to see the picture
of the church that God is wanting to
bring to that in Revelation, he's
saying, "Here's the people that keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus." Right? There's a there's a
group specifically talking about the
144,000 that that have no guile in their
mouth that they are a pure people and
and that's a picture that God wants to
bring us to in our Christian experience
>> there. It's it's a new covenant
experience. The Bible says that God will
put his law
>> in our hearts.
>> That's how they're keeping that. I mean,
it's not done in their own strength.
>> That's right.
>> It's God has put his law in their heart,
so they keep his law.
>> I mean, that's what God wants. I mean,
you know, try to find a place in the
Bible where God says, "Just completely
disregard my law. I don't care about any
of that." Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> It doesn't exist.
>> Yeah. We we actually did a had a long
discussion on this when we did a video
about uh Grand Theft Auto uh 6, the
announcement of Grand Theft Auto 6, and
we had a long discussion on the law and
should you keep the law, should you not?
And so, I think there's probably a lot
of people who have questions will come
up with versus like what about this or
that or that. I would say for those
people, check out that video because we
go really in depth into it more so than
you probably could do right now. But uh
I would say all of the objections that
people have, you can actually find from
the Bible that and I mean this politely
that they can't actually stand once you
compare scripture to scripture and that
we are asked by God to keep the law out
of love for him, not to be
self-righteous or anything and not to be
saved by works like I said, but out of
love for God. Jesus said, "If you love
me, keep my commandments."
>> And if we don't find ourselves there,
then we need to be born again. We need
to be transformed because we're not in
harmony with God. And that's
>> we're not going to go to heaven and be
in disharmony with God,
>> right?
>> It just is not going to work. Even the
Bible says, "Can two walk together
except they be agreed?" God is not going
to populate heaven with a whole bunch of
rebellious people. That just does not
make any sense.
>> So, I like what the Bible says in 1
Peter 1:23. It says, "Having been born
again, not of corruptible seed, but
incorruptible through the word of God,
which lives and abides forever."
>> Yeah. I I I think, like I said,
if you think that movies are just
innocent, and it just so happens that
the tons of movies have the exact same
theme just repackaged and it's just it's
just how it is, you know? There's
nothing sinister about that. I really
think you have to I mean I don't mean to
be self-promoting but hey what just dig
through our channel look at more stuff
that we have because it's really obvious
and once you see it you can't unsee it
>> if you see a pattern that [music]
denotes intelligence and you have to ask
the question why why is there a pattern
>> why is it always coming at this
direction it's not like either or or
both sides it's like always kind of
spoken at as this negative thing that
the villain has
>> yeah and I think about this way how do
you memorize scripture repeating
repeating it, right? Well, why don't you
just create a repeat machine in
Hollywood and you tell the same story
over and over and over and over and over
again? Eventually, it's going to stick.
That story is going to stick and that
theme. And I think that's exactly what's
happening.
[music]